Una recta tiene una pendiente de -3/4
y pasa por el punto 0, 8.
¿Cuál es la ecuación de la línea en
la forma pendiente-ordenada al origen?
Y bueno,
todas las líneas rectas se pueden
escribir de la forma pendiente-ordenada al origen,
que es la siguiente.
"y" es igual a "mx" más "b", donde "m",
esta de aquí es la pendiente,
y "b" es la ordenada al origen,
ésta es donde se intersecta,
al eje de las yes...
la intersección con el eje de las yes...
Y bueno, déjenme graficarla aquí.
Vamos a suponer que  tengo una línea recta en mi plano cartesiano y puede ser cualquier línea recta.
Así que voy a tomarme a mi plano cartesiano,
mis dos ejes coordenados
y bueno,
como tengo una pendiente negativa,
entonces voy a dibujar una línea recta aquí
que tenga pendiente negativa,
es decir, que vaya hacia abajo.
¡Ya está!
Y bueno,
aquí tengo dos conceptos muy importantes.
El primero, es la pendiente, entonces si tenemos esta gráfica de color rojo que tenemos aquí
y yo me tomo dos puntos
que estén sobre esta gráfica,
entonces la pendiente es el cambio en "x",
a comparación de lo que cambia en "y",
es decir, lo que nos mide la pendiente,
es el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x",
que por cierto, como en este caso,
mi recta va hacia abajo,
lo que quiere decir es que cuando yo cambio
en "x"positivamente,
entonces forzosamente,
el cambio en "y "debe de ser negativo,
es decir, hacia abajo.
Y es esto, lo que nos está diciendo que tenemos
una pendiente negativa.
Y de igual manera, si yo me voy hacia arriba,
entonces "x" tendría que cambiar hacia la izquierda
para tener una pendiente negativa.
Y bueno, esto es todo lo que corresponde a la pendiente, hablar del cambio de "y" entre el cambio de "x".
Pero el otro concepto importante,
es la ordenada al origen,
que es justo el punto donde intersectamos
al eje de las yes,
es decir, el punto de la
forma 0, "b".
Y es más, lo puedes ver cuando evaluamos
esta función en "x" igual a 0.
Cuando yo sustituyo el valor de "x"por 0,
me va a quedar que "y" es igual a "m" por 0...
por 0 más "b",
pero "m" por 0 se va,
esto es 0,
entonces simple y sencillamente me queda que
"y" es igual a "b" y claro, ojo,
cuando estamos diciendo que "x" vale 0.
Entonces cuando "x" es 0.
Y esto es justo lo que nos da esto punto de aquí,
el 0, "b", es decir, mi ordenada al origen.
Ahora bien, este problema nos dice
que tenemos una pendiente de -3/4,
es decir, nuestra pendiente es igual a -3/4
y además que pasamos por
el punto 0, 8,
y déjame cambiar de color,
para que no sea anaranjado
y me voy a tomar el color, verde...
Y entonces nos dice que pasa por el punto 0,8.
¿Y qué nos quiere decir esto?
Bueno, entonces estamos parado en el eje de las yes,
en el punto 0, 8
ó dicho de otra manera,
la intersección con el eje de las yes
es en el punto 0, 8,
ó mejor aún, podemos decir que "b" vale 8,
porque fíjate,
aquí tenemos el punto 0, "b"
y entonces aquí nos está diciendo que "b" vale 8.
Y una vez que ya tenemos la pendiente
y  que ya tenemos a "b",
entonces podemos sustituir estos valores
en nuestra ecuación de la recta,
y me queda que
"y" es igual a -3/4 de "x" más "b",
pero "b" vale 8, entonces más 8.
"y" es igual a -3/4 de "x" más 8,
es la respuesta de este problema.